[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le 7 8 c'est votre émission pour
bien démarrer la soirée dans les
Yvelines au programme de l'actualité des
infos pratiques et des idées de sortie
voici les titres de ce lundi 5 juin
ce matin Jean-Noël Barrault ministre de
la transition numérique et des
télécommunications étaient présents à
Buc à l'occasion de l'inauguration du
bâtiment de production de la société
génoptech un fabricant français
spécialisé dans la fibre optique nous
reviendrons sur sa venue
ce lundi marque également le début de la
semaine nationale de la santé sexuelle
contraception maladie sexuellement
transmissibles ou encore violence
sexuelle une table ronde s'est tenues à
Plaisir vendredi 2 juin pour aborder ces
sujets Alice Winde médecin référent du
centre de santé sexuelle de Versailles
nous en parle et puis il y a maintenant
presque deux semaines la DNCG le
gendarme du football français a exclu de
manière provisoire laisse Poissy du
championnat de National 2 le club
yvelinois connaît des difficultés
financières mais ne se résignent pas le
président de l'AS Poissy Olivier seves
succès prépare à faire appel il est
notre invité
et puis comme tous les jours vous le
savez nous sommes accompagnés de
personnes pour nous accompagner durant
cette édition et justement avec nous en
plateau Nathalie Noah bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes la présidente de
l'association Les Enfants de la Terre
donc c'est association qui tente de
venir en aide aux enfants qui sont
confrontés à des situations à d'urgence
comme la maladie par exemple et vendredi
vous avez organisé un tournoi de golf
caritatif pour aider des enfants
hospitalisés comment ça s'est passé
super c'est très agréable très très
belle journée avec plein de sportifs
donc c'était très bien on en parlera
plus amplement tout à l'heure et puis à
vos côtés justement Olivier sevesuc
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le
président du club de football de l'AS
Poissy et le 23 mai dernier donc la DNCG
donc la Direction Nationale de Contrôle
de Gestion a décidé d'exclure Poissy en
tout cas provisoirement des championnats
national pour la saison prochaine en un
mot dans quel état d'esprit ce que vous
êtes aujourd'hui
pas résigné évidemment toujours aussi
combatif je suis un peu le zxi du
football en tant qu'ukrainien parce
qu'on était venu pour en parler
j'essaie de trouver les solutions pas
seul d'ailleurs mais je suis voilà
aujourd'hui dans le combat en essayant
de trouver les solutions pour démontrer
que finalement il y a des éléments qu'on
fait qu'on en est arrivé là et que j'ai
sans doute une part de responsabilité en
tant que Président il faut être toujours
très honnête et très humble néanmoins il
y a eu tas de paramètres qui ont fait
que et voilà on va essayer de pour
sauver les emplois déjà parce que ça
c'est la première des choses ne
serait-ce que tout le travail social qui
a été fait autour aussi pour ne pas
perdre de vue qu'un club c'est beaucoup
de gens c'est 900 licenciés et il serait
dommage que l'image de Poissy par
rapport à une décision que je trouve un
peu un peu compliqué un peu dur et bien
on verra on va se battre on va en parler
on va en parler justement et puis on va
voir quels seront vos prochaines actions
en face de vous également une
journaliste de la rédaction Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir bonsoir alors avec vous
on va parler de l'actualité dans les
Yvelines donc ce sera dans un instant
dans cette édition également nous ferons
également le point sur les résultats
sportifs du week-end et on parlera aussi
de la jovassienne donc c'est une
randonnée à vélo dans la vallée de la
Bièvre avec notre invité donc voilà le
programme est déroulé je vous propose
juste avant ça de jeter un coup d'œil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera toujours aussi
bleu et ensoleillée dans les Yvelines
avec tout de même quelques nuages à
Mantes-la-Jolie et à Versailles au
niveau des températures il fera en
moyenne entre 16 et 17 degrés sur tout
le territoire dans l'après-midi le ciel
sera un peu plus voilé mais les
températures seront estivales avec 26
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et
Versailles et 27 degrés à Rambouillet et
demain ce sera la saint Norbert
maintenant tout de suite les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence les actualités du jour
avec vous Gabriel Gonthier ce matin
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre délégué
chargé de la transition au numérique et
des télécommunications étaient à Buc
pour l'inauguration de la société
génoptech oui tout à fait régime la
société était historiquement basé à
Jouy-en-Josas mais aujourd'hui c'est son
tout nouveau site de production à Buc
qui a été inauguré alors depuis 40 ans
j'ai noté spécialisé dans la fibre
optique et les produits opto
électroniques entre autres elle fabrique
et assemble les câbles fibre optiques
c'est ce qui vous permet par exemple
d'avoir le haut débit internet chez vous
la société travaille avec différents
secteurs comme la défense et l'industrie
ou le broadcast et l'événementiel elle a
comme ambition de développer
l'installation de la fibre en France
notamment de se substituer au réseau
cuivre mais aussi de s'exporter vers des
marchés étrangers le ministre a pu
visiter l'usine de production et
échanger avec les différents ouvriers
sur place on écoute sa réaction ainsi
que celle du dirigeant de l'entreprise
Jérôme nobili on a dans les Yvelines une
longue tradition Télécom et informatique
avec cette
usine puisque c'est une usine de fibre
optique et bien on reste fidèle à cette
tradition et à notre ambition que ce
territoire reste dynamique et à la
pointe de ce qui se fait en matière de
télécommunication je salue la volonté de
cette entreprise qui constatant ou
anticipant qu'on arrive progressivement
au bout du déploiement de la fibre pour
les télécommunications comment ça à se
préparer à des diversifications pour
continuer à se développer et notamment
dans la fibre optique appliquée à
d'autres usages but pour nous c'était
une évidence une évidence parce que tout
simplement il y avait le plateau de
Saclay et là où il y a tous nos clients
et le rayonnement des hautes
technologies sur Buc me paraissait
comme une évidence donc pas loin de la
gare TGV Massy de d'Orly on va pouvoir
bénéficier également donc de toute cette
infrastructure et ses écoles qui je
l'espère pourra en tout cas nous
permettre d'avoir un vivier important de
jeunes talents
et dans l'actualité également des
perturbations sont à prévoir ce mardi
après l'appel des syndicats et une
nouvelle mobilisation oui le pays
pourrait une nouvelle fois être mis au
ralenti demain l'intersadie Calpe
prévoit une je cite grande journée de
grève et de manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites néanmoins de très
légères perturbations sont prévues dans
les transports selon la SNCF train sur
10 seront en circulation dans les écoles
des pertes perturbations sont également
à prévoir le signe FSU des Yvelines
appelle les enseignants à se mobiliser
dans certaines communes des Yvelines les
périscolaires seront également impactés
cette mobilisation elle pourrait
s'installer dans la durée et pour cause
l'Assemblée nationale examine jeudi la
proposition de loi du groupe yote qui
vise à annuler la réforme des retraites
vous l'imaginez si la réponse du
gouvernement ne satisfait pas la
mobilisation pourraient alors se
poursuivre et un autre secteur en
difficulté c'est la santé les Yvelines
ne font pas figures d'exception durant
le mois de juin le dispositif bus santé
fait un grand retour dans le département
oui le bus santé entame une nouvelle
tournée à travers le territoire et les
neuf communes programmées pour
l'accueillir le bus santé c'est ce
dispositif mis en place par le
département il propose des consultations
à distance avec un médecin grâce à un
cabinet de télémédecine équipé de
dispositifs médicaux l'objectif
permettra un service de santé aux
habitants des communes qui subissent le
manque de médecins avec ou sans
rendez-vous vous pourrez profiter des
consultations au cours du mois de juin
dans les 9 communes que vous voyez à
l'écran le bus permet également des
actions de prévention et de dépistage
notamment pour le cancer le VIH ou
encore les addictions et du nouveau qui
pourrait également intéresser les
habitants de Poissy avec l'ouverture
d'une école maternelle et primaire pour
septembre 2024 oui l'éco-quartiers
Rouget de l'Isle à Poissy accueillera
pour la rentrée 2024 un nouveau groupe
scolaire du même nom le chantier il a
débuté fin 2022 vendredi dernier une
visite était organisée en présence de la
présidente de la Région Île Valérie
Pécresse alors le groupe scolaire de
3000 m² devrait compter 300 élèves
répartis en 12 classes de maternelles et
de primaires et Gabriel vous nous parlez
également d'une autre inauguration cette
fois-ci sportif à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
où il a commune à inauguré la seconde et
dernière partie du pot de glisse de la
ville avec l'inauguration du skatepark
et du pump track un skatepark qui a été
pensé et construit avec des pratiquants
locaux de skate une façon aussi de
mettre en avant nos sportifs et Vinois
et on termine cette fois-ci les
informations du jour avec cette info
donc la ville d'Élancourt qui a organisé
ce week-end une nouvelle opération mon
quartier demain oui le but présenter aux
élans courtois les projets à venir dans
leur quartier en 2022 en 2022 c'est le
quartier de la clef Saint-Pierre qui
était concerné cette année l'opération
elle concerne le quartier du village
parmi les futurs projets la
revégétalisation du jardin des 5 sens et
la création de nouveaux espaces
d'activités au bassin de la Muette une
réhabilitation va être réalisée pour
rééquilibrer le milieu aquatique et
stabiliser les berges enfin le village
connaîtra également une nouvelle
signature végétale avec notamment la
création d'un verger participatif bien
merci beaucoup à Gabriel Gontier de nous
partager les informations dans
l'actualité des Yvelines et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous êtes
témoin d'une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
et on en parlait en début d'émission les
enfants de la terre c'est une
association yvinoise qui tente de venir
en aide à certains enfants confrontés à
des situations d'urgence Nathalie Noah
donc vous êtes en plateau avec nous pour
nous en parler vendredi dernier donc
vous avez organisé ce tournoi de golf
caritatif qui s'est bien déroulé ce que
vous avez atteint justement vos
objectifs en termes de dons écoutez oui
nous avons récolté pour cette journée
quasiment 16000 euros
donc c'est très bien ça va pouvoir nous
aider à continuer nos actions et ça
dépassait les objectifs que vous étiez
fixés un petit peu un petit peu en tout
cas c'était un bon c'était un bon
tournoi les gens répondent présents donc
c'était tout allait très bien et alors
pour présenter un petit peu aussi votre
association puisque il était spectateur
ne la connaissent pas forcément donc
elle a été créée en 1988 par
Marie-Claire votre mère et votre frère
Yann est-ce que vous savez pourquoi ils
ont eu aussi ce projet commun et cette
envie d'aider les enfants mais je pense
que déjà on a vécu très peu de temps au
Cameroun et maman avait une école
maternelle et aimait beaucoup les
enfants et en fait quand elle est
rentrée en France elle s'ennuie un petit
peu elle a très bien dans une autre
association et puis un jour elle s'est
dit mais pourquoi pas monter notre
association et c'est comme ça qu'on a
commencé avec nos maisons tendresse on
accueille des enfants on en reparlera
justement tout de suite vous avez des
objectifs multiples que vous intervenez
notamment dans la prévention à la
délinquance vous accompagner aussi les
enfants qui sont hospitalisés ou malades
quels sont finalement vos périmètres
d'action puisque j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a énormément de choses que vous
effectuez en fait au départ à la base
c'était c'était les maisons tendresse on
avait des enfants et pendant toutes les
périodes de vacances scolaires on
accueillait des enfants en difficulté
sociale ou économique et après maman ça
a grandi un petit peu on a commencé à
aider beaucoup les hôpitaux donc on est
beaucoup des hôpitaux donc on a beaucoup
de demandes d'aide parce que les enfants
qui sont hospitalisés très longtemps
souvent les parents n'arrivent soit se
loger à côté de l'hôpital soit à payer
le matériel donc on les aide beaucoup
financièrement et comment est-ce qu'on
peut bénéficier des actions de
l'association ce qui a des critères
spécifiques ou une zone géographique
en général les enfants ne sont envoyés
par des assistants sociales voilà qui
nous appelle au bureau et où les écoles
et on accueille tous les enfants il y a
pas de il y a pas de géocaliser bon bien
sûr on est dans les Yvelines on va pas
faire venir des enfants de Lyon mais
disons que voilà autour de nous Paris
les Yvelines on prend beaucoup d'enfants
et vous parlez de d'urgence d'urgence de
situation d'urgence qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement comme des enfants sont
enlevés à leurs parents quelquefois
quelquefois il y a des voilà des
problèmes avec les parents soit ils sont
placés soit on les accueille dans une
maison vous avez une question depuis la
création de l'association vous vous
rendez compte que le besoin s'accroît au
niveau des enfants il y a de plus en
plus de besoins comment ça fait 10 ans
non 11 ans maintenant que j'ai repris
complètement l'association avant je
travaille avec maman mais que dans le
dans les organisations de d'événements
pour gagner de l'argent mais on a vu on
a senti après le covid qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes et que beaucoup de
beaucoup de demandes d'enfants voilà et
de maman aussi il y a beaucoup de maman
qui nous demandent aussi de t'entendre
les mamans avec leurs enfants pour
essayer de souffler un petit peu ça leur
fait du bien je pense que oui c'est
alors que non sincèrement ça me fait
beaucoup de bien parce qu'on a que des
bons retours et notre association quand
on accueille des enfants dans cette
maison c'est pas une colonie on
accueille 12 enfants on est 4-5
éducateurs c'est vraiment une petite
famille voilà donc ça se passe très bien
et combien de d'événements est-ce que
vous organisez chaque année ça dépend en
fonction de en général on fait le
trophée de golf quelques fois on fait le
foot on fait de la pétanque et après pas
forcément pas forcément si on a qui
veulent faire des événements pour nous
on dit oui malheureusement c'est rare
mais ça arrive
et alors du coup est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous savez à peu près combien d'enfants
ont pu ou de famille ont pu bénéficier
de l'association vous avez des chiffres
en tête depuis qu'on a commencé
on en a écouté oh je peux pas vous dire
depuis qu'on a commencé ah non je peux
pas vous dire et alors
on en est de 200 250 mais depuis je sais
pas et à l'époque on avait plus de
maison là on en a moins parce qu'à
l'époque on avait 5 maisons on en a
gardé plus qu'une maintenant et vous
avez encore contact avec les premiers
enfants que vous avez accompagnés
la première petite fille qui s'appelait
Isis qui est arrivé à six mois qui avait
perdu ses parents et on est toujours en
contact avec elle on en a plein on en a
une bonne dizaine et on est très fiers
parce qu'ils sont genre ils étaient rien
au départ ils sont devenus journalistes
on a des acteurs on a des donc c'est des
belles histoires et c'est important de
les voir évoluer déjà pour nous parce
que moi c'est un sens à ce qu'on fait
parce que c'est pas toujours facile
quand on accueille les enfants on leur
donne du bonheur de l'amour on s'amuse
il s'en vont et plus rien donc on essaie
d'avoir un suivi et le plus beau des
cadeaux c'est quand on reçoit les
lettres des enfants après ces jours ça
c'est très émouvant peut-être en faire
un livre avec tous les souvenirs je
pense qu'on pourrait écrire je pense
qu'on pourrait peut-être quand je
prendrai ma retraite quand je prendrai
ma retraite pourquoi pas non c'est vrai
qu'on a des très belles histoires aux
enfants de la terre et ça fait du bien
de enfin nous on aime donner et
accompagner les enfants donc c'est
c'est parfait vous avez des prochaines
actions qui sont prévues
normalement la pétanque et après dans
cette année normalement on part en
séjour l'alliance ces jours-là on part
très vite parce que tous les thés on est
en séjour donc on a pas d'autres actions
là de prévues merci Nathalie Noah
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et bien
on va continuer justement cette semaine
donc aujourd'hui c'est la Semaine de la
santé sexuelle donc ça démarre
aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 5 juin à cette
occasion le département des Yvelines a
organisé une table ronde vendredi
dernier pour présenter les actions des
centres de santé sexuel et pour parler
d'éducation je vous propose de regarder
tout de suite l'interview Express
d'Alice win qui est médecin référent du
centre de santé sexuelle de Versailles
[Musique]
la santé sexuelle on a l'impression que
c'est très réducteur mais en fait c'est
très très large et si on reprend la
définition de l'OMS c'est vraiment tout
ce qui va toucher la sphère physique
mais aussi mentale affective social du
bien-être et du bien-être en relation
avec la vie affective relationnelle et
sexuelle
[Musique]
de faire connaître le centre de santé
sexuelle comme une ressource parce que
c'est vraiment une vraie richesse sur le
territoire pour toutes les femmes et
même pour les hommes en fait on ne sait
pas assez et de pouvoir discuter de
sexualité d'éducation et vie sexuelle
avec Edwige qui fait plein de contenus
là-dessus qui sont super intéressants et
vraiment ça nous permet de mixer nos
regards
[Musique]
malheureusement on n'est jamais assez
sensibilisé il y a plein plein de choses
à faire et on le voit chez les jeunes on
voit un abord à la sexualité qui est
quand même qui est quand même assez
violent par la pornographie et après
chez les moins jeunes en fait une fois
qu'on a passé l'âge des enfants on
oublie un peu la sexualité alors que
c'est le moment où on pourrait s'éclater
quand il commence à être un peu plus
grand et puis voilà c'est tout au long
de la vie même jusqu'à l'âge de l'EHPAD
la sexualité c'est tout le temps et donc
vraiment il y a une éducation à faire
tout le temps pour pouvoir en profiter
au maximum
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui sédent par
les réseaux sociaux qui séduquent par
les vidéos qui voient et là l'idée c'est
de contrebalancer ça avec du contenu de
qualité et du contenu vraiment
informatif par les réseaux sociaux voilà
l'accès par les réseaux sociaux on peut
plus l'éviter aujourd'hui les jeunes y
ont accès depuis tout petit il suffit
qu'ils aient accès à un téléphone ils
arrivent à trouver la vidéo YouTube et
encore plus vite que leurs parents dès
qu'ils ont 3 ans donc on sait que ça
existe on va pas se voiler la face
autant proposer par ce biais là vraiment
une information et une éducation de
qualité
allez c'est maintenant l'heure de passer
à notre page sport
[Musique]
et dans cette page sport pour nous
accompagner à Nicolas dandry bonsoir
vous êtes aussi journaliste de la
rédaction tv718 alors on commence cette
page de sport avec du sport et un deux
invités Olivier sevesuc vous êtes
président de l'AS Poissy qui connaît des
difficultés Nicolas
de la nationale de l'AS Poissy et sous
la menace d'une relégation en régionale
une en cause une dette qui s'élève à
plus de 250 000 euros une décision
rendue par la direction nationale du
contrôle de gestion de la Ligue
professionnelle de football alors
première question Olivier est-ce que la
laisse passer est en danger pour sa
survie écoutez la survie d'un club étant
en danger pour rester au niveau de
National 2 cela va faire 6 ans que je
suis président adapt c'est la première
fois que je suis confronté à ce problème
là mais c'est vrai que entre
je veux dire les les différentes
réunions que je peux avoir formelles ou
informelles avec Monsieur olive le
député qui m'a nommé il y a 6 ans et
Madame le Maire et ses services on
essaye de trouver ensemble la meilleure
solution pour savoir comment l'on peut à
terme sauver cette équipe de national de
cependant vous savez un club si on n'est
pas en National 2 on peut être National
3 la s.i existera toujours qu'elle soit
nationale 2 en National 3 ou un rein
aujourd'hui la question qu'on peut se
poser comme on en est arrivé là on avait
déjà alerté et j'avais déjà alerté on
était déjà sur un déficit de 150000
euros on a malheureusement
en tant que président avec mon trésorier
et le bureau eu un certain nombre de
problèmes d'ailleurs on s'en était
expliqué ici sur le plateau de mémoire
c'est pas la première fois je viens vous
voir des problèmes de licence 34000
euros des sponsors perdus
ça va très très vite donc la spirale va
très vite il s'avère que voilà on avait
des contrats sur des joueurs qui n'ont
pas étonné par d'autres clubs je vais
citer personne je crois qu'on n'est pas
là et je suis pas là ce soir pour régler
des comptes bien au contraire je suis là
et laisser mon engagement et les gens
qui travaillent avec moi le savent je le
fais bénévolement évidemment j'ai donné
beaucoup de temps comme me dit Monsieur
car le livre et qu'il écrit d'ailleurs
j'ai servi le club peut-être que
certains sont servis à d'autres fins moi
non maintenant l'idée c'est de se dire
qu'est-ce que l'on fait il y a des
emplois il y a des joueurs puisque ce
statut de N2 et vous le savez très bien
c'est l'amateurisme d'un côté les faits
des roues de l'autre on a on a toujours
été entre guillemets entre deux
pourraient pas être vulgaire un peu
bâtard parce que on sait pas trop se
positionner et c'est la difficulté
d'être un ANC j'ai si vous êtes en M3 ou
en R1 vous n'avez pas cette DNCG donc on
m'avait fait des recommandations mais
après j'ai toujours eu l'espérance je
suis dans l'espérance vous me connaissez
vous connaissez mes origines
ukrainiennes j'ai toujours été dans
l'espérance de me dire un jour ça va
s'arranger malheureusement les sponsors
qui m'avaient promis et vous savez les
amis dans ce monde là quand on s'y ni
rien vous devez connaître messieurs
aussi autour de la table vous êtes dans
le monde du sport non pas tenu leur
promesse maintenant je règle aucun
compte ce soir alors l'espoir c'est
demain c'est
cette réunion à la mairie de Poissy
qu'est-ce qui va se passer durant cette
réunion sur l'initiative de Monsieur
carlolive et Madame le Maire l'idée
c'est de mettre un certain nombre de
gens autour de la table pour éviter que
vous savez que ça va très très vite
divulguer des informations qui sont
fausses 500000 € j'ai tout entendu alors
l'idée c'est de se dire voilà tout ce
qui va être mis sur la table déjà on a
fait une réunions ce matin en mes
bureaux je peux pas me déplacer avec Mac
comme il s'est recompte et mon trésorier
pour véritablement démontrer et montrer
un peu les vrais chiffres donc on est
arrivé un constat on voit beaucoup de
chiffres 250000 euros nos confrères du
Parisien mettent 270 000 euros 300000
euros même dans la publication publiée
par Carlos on est sur 252000 euros
d'accord et il s'avère que là on va
juste discuter des raisons pour
lesquelles on était là je vais exposer
un certain nombre de critères et de
chiffres parce que d'important dans ces
cas-là de savoir pourquoi on en est là
les sponsors perdus un certain nombre de
gens la confiance
on y arrive vite des licences non payées
elle a fait des qui nous sanctionne de
34000 ça va très très vite on est
aujourd'hui
si d'aventure sur les 250 000 je n'avais
pas perdu ces choses qui ne sont pas de
mon faites on serait à -100 000 - 100000
comme je l'ai dit aussi à qui de droit
quand l'État français est à 3000
milliards de dates ou certains clubs je
pense que ça aurait fait peut-être
100000 de déficits ça serait pas énorme
aujourd'hui c'est juste pour éclairer un
peu tout le monde sur la situation
surtout pas réglé de compte c'est pas
mon style mais de dire on a peut-être
fait des erreurs la confiance les prix
aussi un certain nombre de choses cette
équipe a tourné n'oubliez pas on était
premier à une époque avant cette
malheureusement cette bêtise qu'il y a
eu les 7 points perdus ah oui les 7
points c'est rien c'est pas de l'argent
mais c'est les 34000 qui ont derrière
qui nous ont fait du mal en plus du
reste et il s'avère que demain on va
l'expliquer en toute honnêteté moi j'ai
aucun problème vous savez quand on est
bénévole comme moi et qu'on a mis du
temps de l'argent parce que le président
de club amateur aujourd'hui enfin on va
dire entre deux
c'est presque un sacerdoce c'est c'est
se faire des nœuds au cerveau et croyez
moi je m'en fais et c'est dommage parce
que mais il y a des emplois à sauver
pour la pérennité du club j'espère que
voilà j'ai des investisseurs j'ai deux
dossiers à présenter ça passe ou ça
casse parce que aussi les gens vous
promettent ne tiennent pas toujours
leurs engagements on en serait peut-être
pas là aujourd'hui mais on va voir
comment les choses s'orientent moi en
tout cas je me borde normal
juridiquement et à partir du moment où
il y a pas le malvoration pardon
malversation je suis pas très inquiet
c'est pour le club pour lequel c'est
tout Nicolas vous avez un mot sur le
volet sportif
jouer la 30e et dernière journée de
National 2 et lourde défaite à
l'extérieur face à l'équipe de du Stade
Rennais 6 buts à zéro l'épiccia qui
termine à la sixième place au classement
alors certes des problèmes et des
difficultés financières mais sixième du
classement comment se sente justement
les joueurs alors une lourde défaite 6-0
ils avaient peut-être pas la tête à
jouer au football ce week-end vous savez
c'est ça encore c'est la difficulté
quand on part en déplacement nous
n'aurons pas toujours les moyens d'avoir
comme des clubs professionnels des cas
on a essayé ça coûte une certaine somme
on essaie d'avoir des partenaires de les
arrêter à l'hôtel il y a quelques années
avec il y a deux trois six ans
maintenant on pouvait faire une sieste
on essayait de trouver un groupe en
l'occurrence je vais pas le citer mais
voilà il aurait pu être notre partenaire
il l'est pas parce qu'ils ont des
problèmes aussi on s'arrêtait dans un
dans un hôtel restaurant il faisait une
petite sieste à trois dans une chambre
on avait un statut quand vous partez en
minibus à Rennes à 7 heures du matin pas
de sieste et là c'est sandwich puisque
j'ai dit on a plus les moyens
aujourd'hui comme on voulait faire un
résultat comme vous ne savez pas si vous
aurez vos salaires comme je ne sais pas
si vos réseaux frais c'est très
compliqué aujourd'hui cette défaite
finalement c'est la résultante on était
et sixième avec ses problèmes là moi je
félicite tout le groupe le staff les
joueurs c'était une année fantastique
moi j'y suis pas allé je fais tous les
déplacements depuis 6 ans quand je peux
mais ils ont fait 80%, et montrer ce que
j'ose même pas parler à mes joueurs pour
vous dire j'ai quelques joueurs au
téléphone mais quand on sait pas quoi
leur dire Président on en est où
je suis malade quoi en fait leur avenir
à eux aussi est-ce que il y en a
certains qui vous ont dit on part on
sait l'attachement de votre coach actuel
aussi au club aussi bien sûr ils veulent
partir où finalement ils vont rester ils
vont se battre avec vous à vos côtés ils
se sont battus parce que aujourd'hui il
y a aucune fronde c'est ça qui est assez
extraordinaire c'est que j'ai eu des
garçons au téléphone qui me disent
président il y a des clubs qui ça parce
que avec les bonnes prestations qu'on
peut faire les uns et les autres
évidemment il y a des clubs soient dans
la région ou même en France qu'on vu
leur prestations à un moment donné
l'équipe de Poissy fonctionnait très
bien d'ailleurs on était deuxième on a
battu Rouen qui monte une fois chez nous
une fois chez eux et ça prouve la
qualité de mon équipe du staff et et
tous les joueurs donc je leur dis je
sais pas quoi vous dire aujourd'hui je
suis pendu à l'adncg c'est quoi la suite
justement pas
en disant c'est très très dur on est
l'appel sera entendu le 4 juillet quand
on s'est préparé une saison
évidemment je la préparais là
aujourd'hui demain près de main c'est
très compliqué qu'est-ce que je vais
dire aux joueurs et encore des salaires
à payer au mois de juin à ce jour je ne
sais pas si je pourrais les honorer
est-ce qu'on va faire
une liquidation judiciaire je voudrais
pas en arriver là ça serait trop dommage
est-ce que des gens vont se mobiliser je
suis presque envie vous voyez comme j'ai
fait pour les Ukrainiens de dire je suis
tellement mobilisé pour pour mes cousins
on va dire pour mes frères quand j'ai
fait cette quête j'ai eu un peu d'argent
j'ai envie de dire les gens qui sont
amoureux de Poissy c'est pas moi c'est
pas mon avenir je suis prêt à laisser le
club pour sauver le club je le laisse
j'ai dit à tout le monde j'ai pas
d'avenir personnel j'étais 10 ans
président du nid on connaît mon
application ma médaille de mérite pour
ça tout ce que j'ai pu faire chez mes
amis des SOS Racisme juste avant
d'arriver là qui m'ont appelé tout à
l'heure vice-président en me disant mais
mais tout ce que tu as fait de toute
façon il faut pas te rendre malade il
faut dire des vérités et je le dis avec
mon cœur d'ailleurs j'étais quand même
oui un peu ému que Carl dit ces mots sur
moi et encore ce matin par téléphone en
disant que t'as rien à te reprocher
quelques erreurs on en fait parce qu'on
a envie quand on est président comme moi
qu'on est qu'on est toujours auprès de
ses joueurs que cette adrénaline dans le
vestiaire j'ai quand même été joueur et
un joueur qui a joué aussi au niveau
entre guillemets national toute ma
carrière pratiquement voilà quoi ce
sentir comme ça pas abandonné parce que
personne m'a abandonné néanmoins je
pense que vous me poserez la question le
PSG arrive alors justement le Paris
Saint-Germain qui arrive au campus cet
été ils vont s'installer l'équipe
l'équipe va jouer maintenant
juste en face de chez vous c'est le PSG
vous avez eu des contacts avec eux vous
avez fait une lettre au président
parce qu'on aura cours de temps
avec mon cœur je sentais déjà que
c'était compliqué sans lui demander de
l'argent déjà le lui dire que j'ai joué
ou pas j'ai porté les couleurs et que
j'adore ce club que j'ai trois
abonnements depuis 30 ans que c'est mon
club et que voilà bienvenue mais je
voulais lui dire aussi si on pouvait se
rencontrer vous avez envie de donner
votre amour j'étais toujours donné aux
autres toute façon c'est ma conviction
c'est que partage mais voilà même je
comprends d'autres chats fouetter que la
laisse Poissy néanmoins c'est vrai que
j'aurais bien voulu participer avoir des
joueurs de chez eux des jeunes je rêvais
un certain nombre de choses ce qui est
normal je suis président et même pour
mes jeunes après écouter vous savez moi
je suis voilà je suis croyant j'ai la
foi j'ai bienveillance pour les autres
et je crois qu'un jour peut-être que les
choses vont évoluer en toute humilité
j'y crois un peu encore il faut être
dans l'espérance toujours les derniers
mots merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
Nicolas on continue les résultats
sportifs et cette fois-ci on va parler
du pari Saint-Germain on en parlait
juste à l'instant onzième titre de
champion de France pour le PSG une
cérémonie haut en couleur avec des feux
d'artifice et des images sur l'histoire
du club une célébration avec une pensée
aussi et un hommage pour le gardien
espagnol sergio Rico victime d'un
accident de cheval toujours plongé dans
le coma un moment entaché néanmoins
parler hués dirigés vers l'entraîneur
Christophe Galtier et le grand le la
Pulga Lionel Messi et on écoute à ce
propos le gardien parisien et
international italien John Luca de
darumba au micro de Grégory canalet
chacun fait ce qu'il veut
Léo c'est l'histoire du football il a
marqué cette histoire
je pense que c'est le meilleur au monde
et donc je lui souhaite le meilleur
après il est normal que les supporters
ne soient pas tellement heureux après
cette saison
et nous les comprenons car nous avons
perdu un peu trop de matchs et ça ce
n'est pas bien
il faut nous améliorer et aller de
l'avant essayez de faire mieux l'an
prochain et se fixer des objectifs
importants
et une autre information football
Nicolas informations de nos confrères de
l'équipe Alexandre Mulliez petit-fils du
fondateur du groupe Auchan nouvelle
actionnaire majoritaire du FC Versailles
près de 3 millions d'euros vont être
investis par et bien ce petit-fils du
fondateur du groupe Auchan avec son bras
droit Fabien Lazare il devrait occuper
des fonctions opérationnelles à
Versailles cinquième du classement
national à la fin de la saison le club
bibinois rencontre aussi des difficultés
financières à Poissy cette fois-ci avec
du basket-ball et oui c'est historique
le poids si basket association a
décroché ça montait en National lune une
ascension obtenue après la victoire en
quart de finale retour 93 71 face à vos
Evia holtcheme et on regarde tout de
suite la joie des joueurs dans les
vestiaires
[Applaudissements]
alors les demi-finales et la finale se
dérouleront ce samedi 10 et dimanche 11
juin à Vannes en Bretagne Poissy
affrontera Lons-le-Saunier dans sa
demi-finale ce samedi à 20h l'épicéa qui
sont en route vers le titre de National
2 un titre déjà décroché deux fois dans
leur histoire en 1989 et en 1992 et un
mot de baseball à présent 9e journée de
la division une du championnat de France
les Cougars de Montigny-le-Bretonneux se
déplaçait chez les boucaniers de La
Rochelle le premier match a été remporté
par les inimmontins 5 à 0 dans la
seconde rencontre les rochers se sont
imposés 9 à 4 au classement les cougars
sont 3e de leur poule et de la voile
pour terminer et des nouvelles du
navigateur yvinois Louis Burton
Louis Burton et son COA skipper Davy
Bodart sont vont redéployer
prochainement la voile de l'immoka
bureau Vallée au programme une première
course la Rolex Fanette depuis couse en
Angleterre jusqu'à Cherbourg c'est le 22
juillet prochain puis le rendez-vous de
l'année 2023 et bien ce sera le 29
octobre prochain avec Transat Jacques
Vabre départ du Havre pour rejoindre la
Martinique Régine et alors une dernière
information qui vient de nous parvenir
Fabien Galtier et le staff de l'équipe
de France de rugby viennent de dévoiler
un premier groupe de 23 joueurs pour
préparer la Coupe du Monde vous le savez
qui aura lieu en France 1er match le 8
septembre prochain face à la
Nouvelle-Zélande un premier groupe qui
regroupe en fait des joueurs qui ont qui
ne jouent plus le Top 14 il y a
plusieurs équipes du championnat de Top
14 qui ont été éliminés et parmi ces
joueurs et bien on retrouve Léo barré
livinois vous le savez le talentueux
yvelinois qui joue au Stade Français
aujourd'hui et bien il est dans le
groupe pour ce premier groupe prépa pour
préparer et bien la Coupe du monde de
rugby et merci beaucoup à Nicolas on
continue cette page sport avec du tennis
une saison 2023 au top pour le Tennis
Club de plaisir et pour en parler son
président est en plateau avec nous
Charles Giordano bonsoir bonsoir alors
et bien merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui Nicolas vous avez une
première la question pour démarrer
qu'est-ce qu'il fait cette réussite on
voit le petit bandeau la tema de cette
thématique je sais et saison réussie
pour le Tennis Club de plaisir oui en
effet vous savez ce club a grandi moi
j'ai vieilli mais il a grandi avec moi
ça fait 34 ans que je suis président
donc j'ai bien vu toutes les étapes et
bien entendu
quand on voit plaisir une ville de 30000
habitants environ avec une équipe de
filles ont prouvé c'est-à-dire les 20
meilleures équipes de France les garçons
qui viennent d'accéder à la première
division nationale on est au-dessus du
des 24 équipes de voilà donc c'est une
grande satisfaction pour le président
pour les mes collègues dirigeants pour
les joueurs voilà tout à l'heure j'ai
j'ai bu les paroles de mon collègue de
Poissy qui équipe entre parenthèses est
une belle personne je vous connais pas
mais mais vraiment vos propos m'ont
touché en tout cas parce que
je suis un peu de ce moule là quand on
est là dedans qu'on est bénévole et
qu'on qu'on vit sa passion voilà c'est
une belle vie moi je dis c'est une belle
vie je souhaite à tout le monde de faire
ça quoi voilà c'est quoi votre secret du
coup
je me dis tant que j'ai de la santé tant
que j'ai ma tête qui fonctionne bien
voilà je veux rester actif je veux
rester dynamique je veux organiser je
veux avoir quelques succès sportifs
voilà je suis comme ça et c'est dans
c'est dans ma c'est dans mes jeunes ça
voilà
et bon j'essaie de transmettre ça à tous
mes jeunes et les moins jeunes
d'ailleurs aussi parce que Tennis Club
de plaisir n'est pas seulement un club
de compétiteur il est aussi un club de
loisirs où il fait bon venir y jouer
Nicolas vous en êtes le témoin
de donc voilà vous alors on a on a des
projets intéressants et puis cette année
nonobstant les deux les deux équipes
fanions nous avons des résultats
prometteurs parce que notre équipe de
chez les garçons
vient d'obtenir sa quatrième victoire et
ce sera déterminant le dimanche prochain
pour la montée en championnat de France
car nous sommes avec l'équipe de on prêt
National et nous allons nous retrouver
si les choses se passent comme je
l'entends et comme je le supplie de
fortement et bien nous allons nous
retrouver avec trois équipes au
championnat de France bon il va falloir
gérer bien sûr il va falloir frapper à
la porte de certains partenaires qui
sont plus des mécènes parce que souvent
c'est des copains qui veulent vous
mettre un billet dans le club c'est
souvent comme ça et donc voilà je
continuerai à
œuvrer dans ce sens-là qu'est-ce que ça
représente d'avoir justement ces deux
équipes fanions au niveau national dans
le tennis ça représente quoi le niveau
national bah écoutez quand on dit c'est
une famille moi moi j'étais le foot
c'était mon sport de prédilection quand
j'étais jeune parce que j'ignorais même
ce côté un cours de tennis quand j'avais
et alors donc c'est pour ça que je vous
dis il y a il y a des choses qui qui ne
s'expliquent pas mais il y a des
émotions il y a des
qui ne se ressentent que dans ces
moments-là de sport le sport amène à
plein de choses il y a pas seulement le
problème éducatif bien sûr j'en suis
persuadé parce que tous ces jeunes qui
sont là nous avons un rôle éducatif
aussi nous n'avons pas seulement qu'un
rôle de d'amener ces jeunes à un bon
niveau non il faut savoir le leur dire
bonjour monsieur au revoir monsieur etc
il faut qu'il sache un peu que la vie
c'est une vie sociale s'il faut un peu
pas vivre en ermite et c'est ça c'est
clair alors ceci étant et comment
voulez-vous je vous dise quand je vais
au club pour moi c'est en bas de
jouvence voilà voilà
je suis bien accueilli alors évidemment
la première chose qu'on me dit ah ben
vous savez président là les trucs sont
bouchés là il y a le truc ici les
petites choses quoi qu'il faut régler il
faut régler mais dans l'ensemble voilà
deux dernières questions qui sont
forcément liées d'abord celle qui fâche
un peu le mois vous verrez après ma
dernière question le tournoi fut c'est
toujours des réussites c'est aussi la
création de pépites parce qu'il y a
plusieurs grands joueurs qui sont passés
d'abord par ce tournoi dans la catégorie
Jeune et qu'on voit aujourd'hui briller
sur et bien les cours internationaux
bien sûr bien sûr c'est un passage
obligé pour tous les champions de demain
c'est tournoi c'est le seul tournoi en
Île-de-France de chez le catégorie on
est c'est un tournoi qui a price monnaie
de 25000 dollars plus l'hébergement des
joueurs c'est un gros budget c'est un
budget qui avoisine les 70 000 euros
donc il faut aller les chercher les sous
et là je remercie quand même le premier
sponsor qui est la ville de plaisir je
dis il faut remercier Madame le Maire et
puis son maire avant au sport parce que
vous savez quand on gère des
installations municipales je sais pas si
c'est votre cas aussi quand on gère des
installations municipales il faut être
aussi reconnaissant il faut savoir la
reconnaissance
commence à perdre de son sens en France
et ça je suis un peu désolé de ça mais
ça je il faut l'être prochaine date du
tournoi
et on commencera les premières les
signatures le 10 septembre pour finir le
17 au le dimanche 17 où vous êtes invité
Nicolas bien entendu voilà dernière
question qui fâche
à Roland-Garros dès le deuxième tour
plus aucun Français en lice qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est le problème c'est
quoi c'est la formation dans le tennis
c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe votre
analyse Charles
que moi vous savez nous avons les moyens
en France au tennis il y a les moyens
nous avons les installations
nous avons de bons de bons gestionnaires
et aussi de bons entraîneurs mais il y
en a mais on a toujours réussi jusqu'à
l'âge de 17 18 ans on a eu des champions
du monde de cette catégorie là et après
et après le dernier palier est très
difficile à franchir pour nos jeunes
pour le jeune Français alors d'aucun
diront
et ben ils sont trop gâtés déjà
c'est parfois le raisonnement que je
peux tenir parce que quand je vois les
les nations qui qui sortent des
champions des petites nations avec des
moyens moindres que les nôtres je me dis
mais on ne peut pas un criminer l'un ou
l'autre vous savez et puis les champions
c'est pas tous les jours c'est pas tous
les jours vous le savez comme moi donc
il y a parfois c'est comme dans nos
clubs il y a les recrues bon il y a des
bonnes années des bonnes années voilà
c'est comme ça c'est le problème voilà
accepter notre invitation et pour
poursuivre cette page de sport on va
maintenant parler de la dernière étape
du Tour de France 2023 qui partira du
Vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines dans un peu plus d'un mois pour
l'occasion le département des Yvelines
et la commune de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ont organisé un week-end de
manifestations sportives un reportage de
Grégory canalet et Mélanie poquet pour
revenir ici dans deux tours mais ces
deux tours en pédalant debout je ne
m'assois pas sur la selle le BMX on est
toujours debout embarqué sur la planète
cyclisme au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce week-end
ont fêté le vélo sous toutes ses formes
très bien un peu un peu compliqué on a
qu'on fasse un peu de vélo mais sinon à
part ça c'était bien restez longtemps
debout
sur ce type de vélo c'est dur c'est une
très bonne initiative et qu'il faut
continuer peut-être faire plus de
publicité du coup là dessus pour les
familles et finalement peut-être incité
aussi les parents parce que finalement
les enfants ils sont très favorables à
faire de du vélo la dernière étape du
Tour de France partira une fois de plus
des Yvelines le département organisé
donc à nouveau la fête du Tour cette
mobilité douce pour laquelle
actuellement nous faisons énormément de
travaux que ce soit le département le 50
ans en Yvelines ou la ville de Montigny
pour permettre aux gens demain de se
déplacer davantage à vélo c'est un enjeu
très fort donc il y a l'aspect sportif
et il y a l'aspect aussi formation et
sensibilisation
démonstration atelier de réparation
baptême soirée festive le but faire
découvrir les différentes disciplines du
cyclisme qu'elle soit olympique ou non
souvent on a un format chaud pour que
les gens découvrent un petit peu les
démonstrations découvrent les tricks
parce que souvent les gens ne
connaissent pas le BMX flat et là vu
qu'on a un format duo aujourd'hui c'est
toujours un petit peu sympa de ce
challenger j'ai une discipline du BMX
qui se pratique uniquement au sol c'est
freestyle et il y a pas besoin de
mobiles
[Musique]
rendez-vous le 23 juillet prochain pour
assister au départ du peloton du Tour de
France avec comme objectif le maillot
jaune qui cette fois ne prendra pas au
bout d'un fil
et on prend maintenant la direction de
Jouy-en-Josas ou une éco rando VTT se
tiendra un dimanche 11 juin au programme
de cette journée 5 parcours proposés
animation musicale et tombola aussi
alors pour en parler avec nous un
plateau Bernard desmary bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le président de
l'association les castors grimpeurs
première question les castors grimpeurs
d'où est-ce que ça vient ce nom voilà la
vallée de la Bièvre la vallée de la
bière jouit dans dans la vallée de la
Bièvre je changeais dans la vallée de la
Bièvre donc tout naturellement dans la
vie de la bière il y a eu des castors
maintenant malheureusement il y en a
plus voilà nous les castors grimpeurs
pourquoi parce qu'en fait quand on sort
de jouis on monte soit sur Vélizy soit
sur le plateau de Saclay donc les
castors grimpeurs je va tiens voilà d'où
est né le nom de notre association en
tout cas ça reste ça reste en tête alors
justement pour présenter un peu votre
association au téléspectateurs ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
c'est que du VTT c'est que du VTT depuis
peu on a une petite section aussi travel
qui se met en route voilà et nous avons
une cinquantaine d'adhérents voilà 50
adhérents moyenne d'âge assez élevé
autour de 35 jusqu'à 50 ans voire plus
mais le VTT c'est pour tous les âges
voilà et donc peut-être prochainement
une structure jeune qui va se mettre en
place voilà dans le cadre aussi de des
aides avec la FF vélo puisqu'on est fait
on est fédéré par la Fédération
Française de vélo enseignement FFC voilà
et donc maintenant pourquoi pas d'ici
quelques années mettre en place une
école pour les jeunes au niveau de du
VTT et alors dimanche 11 juin c'est la
20e édition de la jovassienne il y a
plusieurs parcours qui sont proposés
comment ça se passe si on est débutant
si on expérimenté
trois parcours de VTT 25 km 37 km et 57
km donc en fait plus on monte un
kilomètre plus il y a la difficulté
aussi bien difficulté technique et puis
difficultés au niveau du dénivelé voilà
ce qui fait qu'on est quand même c'est
quand même je dirais
ne serait-ce que passer une racine
d'arbres ou par ces petites marge un
petit rocher c'est quelquefois cette
équipe parce qu'il faut avoir une
position particulière voilà par rapport
au centre de gravité par rapport au
passage avec les roues ou autres porter
un casque ça c'est important donc toutes
les personnes qui sont qui vont venir à
la jonatienne porteront porteront un
casque et ça fait partie du règlement
voilà donc à minimum d'équipements aussi
voilà qui a mis le bag voilà puisque on
parlait d'un petit peu écran d'eau de
sur notre sur notre manifestation entre
autres on a plus du tout de je dirais de
gobelets plastiques sur les
ravitaillements on a plus du tout de on
essaye au maximum si vous voulez d'être
dans dans une développement durable sur
notre manifestation voilà donc
manifestation éco-responsable d'ailleurs
à ce sujet là on a eu un prix l'année
dernière au niveau du Comité
Départemental Olympique et Sportif de de
la première étoile premier niveau par
rapport à notre éco-responsabilité sur
notre manifestation
du coup c'est pas une course et surtout
une randonnée finalement le but c'est
quoi c'est de la découverte les
personnes partent dans une quand ils
veulent arrive quand ils veulent aussi
voilà donc avec des ravitaillements tout
au long du parcours une animation à
l'arrivée voilà on a plein de alors en
plus c'est la 20e édition ça va être
aussi musical ça va être festif il y
aura une belle tombola avec des vélos à
gagner on aura vraiment on va dire on
met le paquet voilà vous avez parlé de
la Gravelotte c'est une des évolutions
mais comment on fait évoluer justement
une course comme celle-là sur 20 ans
puisque c'est la 20e édition bah je
pense que
de plus en plus dans la convivialité
dans le plaisir de venir partager sur
des sur des parcours on varie aussi les
les parcours ou comme on peut parce que
c'est vrai que sur la région parisienne
a toujours à passer des lignes de chemin
de fer quelques fois voilà c'est pas on
n'a pas je dirais une marche de de
changement de parcours tous les ans et
on arrive malgré tout à trouver des
nouveaux parcours donc on est assis par
rapport à ça assez fier de cela et puis
je pense que là on va utiliser comment
c'est la plus dure la 20e édition où
parce que c'est le même pas spécialement
mais bon je pense que des habitudes
verront que on a il y a des nouveautés
quoi là c'est l'objectif c'est la
surprise bien sûr sur votre site web on
peut également voir que l'événement est
gratuit pour les jeunes demandent de 18
ans et pour les femmes pourquoi ce choix
on a voulu mettre alors trois trois
choses en action cette année
déjà au niveau des féminines je pense
que c'est bien d'amener les féminines au
niveau du du VTT voilà et du vélo en
général les plus jeunes aussi donc là on
a fait une gratuité par rapport à ça et
puis on va mettre aussi en exerce tous
les la partie du début du bénévolat
puisque là moi depuis 20 ans j'entre 55
et 70 personnes qui sont bénévoles à la
manifestation donc c'est un temps
d'organisation c'est un temps de
préparation c'est un temps de présence
et je pense que c'est vraiment des
choses c'est de les remercier voilà et
donc par rapport au par rapport aux
jeunes ou au féminines tout à fait ça
sera ça se régale gratuité voilà ça fait
partie de l'idée la vingtième édition de
la Jurassienne aussi par rapport à
toutes les voilà et justement pour
revenir sur les féminines vous vous
remarquez qu'il y a une différence entre
la participation masculine et féminine
il y a beaucoup moins de femmes
je pense qu'on est on est autour de 10%
en pratique féminine sur le sur le je
vois sur la java ciel à peu près sur les
ans si on fait au fil des années c'est à
peu près ça on espère passer le cap
d'arriver à 15 % progressivement voilà
parité bon bien sûr pourquoi pas mais
c'est vrai que là on peut je pense oui
oui on peut augmenter le chiffre là en
plus on va voir des personnes qui vont
encadrer et accompagner les les
féminines sur sur les parcours c'est le
plus simple parcours une question par
rapport à l'année prochaine 2024 Jeux
Olympiques on sait que le VTT c'est
juste à côté est-ce que vous avez déjà
vous réfléchissez déjà à une édition un
peu spéciale à 21e édition du coup mes
spéciales par rapport aux Jeux
Olympiques justement je pense qu'avec
avec la ville de Jouy-en-Josas et j'en
profite pour remercier Madame le Maire
qui justement nous aide beaucoup toute
la partie logistique et puis aide même
et financière sur pour réussir de
manifestation je pense que en tant que
jouir Joseph terre de jeu on va en plus
derrière bien entendu amener une
animation complémentaire supplémentaire
sur la prochaine édition de la Juventus
après sous quelle c'est dans la
réflexion pour l'instant
chaque chose
on verra l'avenir mais c'est vrai que
une année olympique on peut
difficilement passer à côté surtout si
proche de du VTT qui sera sur la colline
Élancourt c'est ça serait quand même
dommage de pas de pas en profiter quoi
voilà nous serons présents dernière
question peut toujours s'inscrire pour
les vêtements oui oui tout à fait
jusqu'à jeudi soir on peut s'inscrire
sur internet sur le site de la
joassienne il y aura peut-être des
places disponibles sur le sur le centre
sportif de Jouy-en-Josas dimanche matin
tout ça va dépendre de nombre d'inscrits
d'ici à jeudi soir voilà et on clôture
jeudi soir les inscriptions avec une
petite marge de d'inscription sur place
bien entendu parce qu'il faut quand même
accueillir du monde et puis ce serait
dommage de de laisser à la porte des VTT
voilà donc bienvenue au vététiste
bienvenue au gravelle on peut dire ceux
qui font un peu de gravier du gravel
road voilà et puis voilà on espère avoir
une belle édition de la 20e édition
merci beaucoup Bernard des maris d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'œil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera toujours aussi
bleu et ensoleillé dans les Yvelines
avec tout de même quelques nuages à
Mantes-la-Jolie et à Versailles au
niveau des températures il fera en
moyenne entre 16 et 17 degrés sur tous
les territoires et dans l'après-midi le
ciel sera un peu plus voilé les
températures seront tout de même
estivales avec 26 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan et Versailles
et 27 degrés à Rambouillet et demain je
le rappelle ce sera la saint Norbert et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir été avec nous je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur TV 78 et
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]